what's going on guys today we're going
over some of the details from chapter
of my hero academia the official chapter
has now been released
and it's cleared a lot of things up that
weren't entirely clear from these
spoilers
for example bakago's chances of survival
and also
how all for one has seemingly stolen
shiguraki's body
there was also one moment that seemed to
have been an error from harakoshi
although you guys let me know your
opinions on that when we get to it
okay so the first thing i need to clear
up about this chapter is a common
misconception about the state of deku's
arms
from the comments on my spoiler review i
noticed that some people
thought that eerie had totally healed
deku's arms of all
injuries way back in the overhaul arc
but that is just not the case
she didn't fix any long lasting problems
that came from his battle with muscular
this is why chapter 285 opens with the
flashback of deku being warned
that he could lose the use of his arms
if he keeps getting injured like
horikoshi wouldn't put that in there if
if it was completely pointless if deku
was healed
so clearly his injuries are still there
despite that he does not hold back
and i need you guys to appreciate what
i'm about to say deku and shigeraki are
super high in the sky right now like
really really high
yet the blowback from midoriya's punches
was enough to cause
this level of ridiculous damage on the
ground below
i don't know what's more impressive the
fact that deku can actually do this
or the fact that shiguraki can take all
of this and not die
by this point deku has given shigaraki
four 100
smashes in quick succession and down on
the ground you can see
manuel is coming to terms with the
realization that a first-year student
could probably beat him up as i
explained in my spoiler review
bakugou jets off into the sky with
endeavour and shoto by his side
and what we now learn from the official
translations is that whilst rockwork was
worried for the students he then thinks
to himself that he's
acknowledged them as heroes and trusts
them to do the job correctly
during the flashback scenes that follow
this moment we get a look back to
episode one
when bakago brutally mocked deku in
front of the entire class
for being quirkless i think potentially
one of the reasons we are seeing this
flashback in particular
is because by the end of these events
that are happening bakugou himself may
be quirkless i'm not saying it's going
to happen 100
or anything but by the end of this video
you'll see what i'm thinking
the scene then flashes back even further
to a moment we've never seen before
in these panels we see a really young
deku and bakugou
watching all might on the tv as he saves
a civilian from a monster
this is the moment that i think
potentially could have been a mistake
from harukoshi
but let me know what you guys think when
we look at all my shoulders there is
clearly smoke coming from them
which of course is what usually happens
when he's at the limit
of holding his muscle form from our
understanding
all might was in good shape up until his
battle with all for one
which was five years before the first
episode of the series
it was only after that moment that his
health deteriorated
and this was best demonstrated by this
graph that we saw in the first maya
academia movie
and given the timelines here i mean look
how young deku and bakugo are this
clearly
wasn't five years ago it's clearly way
before that which means that all might
should have been perfectly healthy
we all know the connotations with all
might and smoke like harakoshi has
basically established that since day one
so i think it just may have been a
mistake but let me know
following this we get a cool combination
of the past and the present
in which bakugou looks up at deku
fighting shigaraki
and remembers his words way back in
chapter 8 in which midoriya said that he
would no longer be the punching bag deku
but instead he's the deku who always
does his best
this was a nice touch from hirokoshi and
a very cool way of signifying deku's
growth right
way back in chapter eight he was almost
in a sense he was afraid to face back a
girl like you can see it in his face
and now he's fighting shigeraki who is a
million times stronger than bagago
and deku just has no fear he doesn't
care about himself
he's thinking about saving everyone else
regardless of what happens to him
moving on though the two most
interesting aspects of this chapter
are located in its final pages number
one is the return of all for one
and number two is bakago's sacrifice to
protect deku
if you've seen my spoiler review you'll
know that endeavor grabs shiguraki and
then unleashes
his prominence burn but it's at this
moment
that afo seemingly swoops in and hijacks
tomorrow's body
from the leaks that came out on thursday
this was not clear at all
but now we get the clarification that
yeah afo is now
just in control earlier in the chapter
shiguraki was begging himself
almost to find a quirk that could deal
with deku and it seems that in this
moment
afo has answered that call it reminds me
of when your brother or sister will ask
you for help on a game
and then instead of telling them what to
do you just grab the controller and do
it yourself
that said it's unclear exactly how long
afo
is about to be in control because many
chapters ago
we saw how his spirit was trying to
control shigaraki in a sense
but shiggy was able to destroy that
vestige and
i thought that was the end of it the
fact that he was able to show shiguraki
so much compassion up until this point
that was surprising so the idea that it
was all a facade and in reality
he just wanted some he just wanted a
backup body all along
i can believe that either way this new
and improved awful one looks
absolutely hideous and whilst i don't
know what this speech bubble is meant to
say
i imagine it's similar to one of those
noises you would hear in the last of us
the official translation clarifies that
all for one says the words
little brother when targeting deku with
forced quirk activation
a similar thing happened a few chapters
ago in that afo doesn't really see one
thrall as just a quirk
but rather he sees it as the
personification
of his little brother in my opinion
there's probably more to the story of
off one and his brother than we've been
told about
because i mean as we know afo's brother
didn't even really like him to begin
with
so what's all for one's obsession with
him like why is he so desperate for them
to have a reunion
clearly there must be more to the story
the chapter ends with bakugou pushing
deku
out of the way and sacrificing himself
but now that i've had more time to think
about it
i'm even more certain that bakugou is
going to survive
the reason i say that is because the
blow that bakako took
was originally intended for deku and
naturally all for one wouldn't kill deku
until he could steal one for all first
that means by default
that this blow was not meant to be
critical it's not meant to kill someone
so for the time being at least bakago is
alive
and next chapter i just you know what
the likelihood is
that all for one is just going to let
baka go drop down to the floor
in the same way that he did for
endeavour because he doesn't really care
about them it's all about stealing one
for all
worst case scenario is that all for one
pulls back ago towards him
and steals his quirk in much the same
way he intended to do for deku
if that was to happen it would of course
mean that bakago
essentially sacrificed his quirk to save
deku which would be
incredibly poetic because as we all know
bakugou
bully deku for being quirkless for so
long so to then
lose his own quirk to save deku yeah
that's that's full circle right there
either way the fact still remains that
bakugou endeavor
and deku are now seriously injured and
it seems that next chapter
shoto might get the chance to shine
because everyone else is super exhausted
super injured super tired shoto is the
is the the latest person to join the
battlefield
so i would hope that he has enough
energy to
to put up a fight but anyway let me know
down below
what did you guys think of this chapter
and how high do you rate the chances of
bakugou losing his quirk
do be sure to subscribe as i'll be
discussing next week's chapter on the
channel as well
and until then peace out